vous êtes avec la sénatrice socialiste
de paris marie pierre de la gontrie oui
marie pierre de la gontrie tout d'abord
votre réaction
ainsi propos d'alexandre benalla qui est
ri donc la commission denquête
parlementaires qui jugent qu'elle est
contraire aux principes fondamentaux de
notre démocratie et de notre
constitution
écoutez je pense que cette volte face
hier était un peu ridicule il s'est
exprimé par communiqué c'est assez
étrange parce que je pense que le mieux
c'est qu'il arrête de parler
journalistes excusez moi hein
faire des des jt de 20 heures qui
viennent devant la commission
tranquillement comme les autres l'ont
fait et puis voilà comme ça nous posons
des questions il répondra et ne répondra
pas et tout ça est normal et il faut
qu'il fasse attention me semble-t-il
parce que il donne l'impression avec
sept épisodes d'hier de considérer que
la loi ne doit pas s'appliquer à lui
parce que vous savez mise intérieur est
venu le secrétaire général de l'elysée
le directeur de cabinet du président le
préfet de police
aucun d'entre eux n'a eu mourait d'envié
de venir dans comme son enquête
j'imagine pourtant ils sont venus parce
qu'ils connaissent les textes ils savent
qu'ils doivent s'y soumettre
là on a quelqu'un qui nous dit je ne
viendrai pas et puis je viendrai et puis
d'ailleurs ce que vous faites n'est pas
légitime et c'est donc qu'ils nous
donnent à voir peut-être eu un aspect de
sa personnalité
c'est à dire il veut faire comme il
l'entend mais aussi quand on lui
rappelle les règles de manière un peu
ferme finalement il les respecte et
peut-être que certains à l'elysée aurait
été bien inspiré de le faire et ça
aurait peut-être évité que tout ça parte
dans tous les sens mais voilà donc vous
savez moi je suis avocate je considère
que les personnes qui sont en difficulté
ont le droit d'être injuste il a envie
de dire que nous ne sommes pas légitime
nous sommes d'ailleurs il vient qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ce qu'a pu a
déclaré la garde des sceaux ce matin
nicole belloubet qui a dit qu'il y avait
peut-être eu une instrumentalisation et
qu'on peut avoir une lecture politique
des événements de cet été à propos de
cette commission denquête jeu très
étonné de la prise de position de la
garde des sceaux de l'expression même de
la garde des sceaux depuis hier c'est
quelqu'un que je respecte je ne la
connaissais pas je vais steam nous ne
sommes pas d'accord sur un certain
nombre de projets mais pourquoi est elle
allait s'exprimer dans une affaire où
évidemment il faut
veiller de manière extrêmement précise à
la séparation des pouvoirs où il y a
forcément une suspicion peut être un
fantasme de liens encore aujourd'hui
entre la personne poursuivie alexandre
benalla et le pouvoir
j'ai envie de caisse qu'elle est allé
faire dans cette galère et donc ce matin
effectivement je l' ai entendu elle a
voulu ré expliquer les choses
elle sert fourvoyé c'est un petit peu
inélégant mais voilà en expliquant des
choses alors après peut-être at elle
découvert que oui cette affaire une
incidence politique pourquoi parce
qu'elle elle révèle une conception du
pouvoir
elle révèle qu' on peut effectivement
faire une sortie de route grave
commettre une infraction pénale
vraisemblablement ce qu'a fait alexandre
benalla le 1er mai si c'est confirmé par
la justice et ne pas être sanctionné et
finalement voir l'elysée ne réagir que
lorsque le 18 juillet c'est à dire deux
mois et demi après la presse révèle
cette affaire c'est à dire si la presse
n'avait pas révélé cet épisode il ne se
serait rien passé
donc moi je serais mal à mme belloubet
que encore une fois j'ai j'estime je
pense que je me garderai à longue
distance de cette affaire et que je ne
m'exprimerai surtout pas en reste
alexandre bédat là bas donc être
auditionnés prochainement ne sait pas
encore la date
finalement alors retour tout de même aux
auditions de ce matin vous allez
notamment entendre le chef de cabinet
des manuels macro françois-xavier lochte
est aussi une audition très attendue
qu'est ce que vous allez lui poser comme
question vous savez depuis le début moi
je rappelle que le rôle de la commission
denquête qui est un rôle constitutionnel
c'est de contrôler l'action des pouvoirs
publics et le gouvernement est de faire
éventuellement des préconisations sera
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
ça a dysfonctionné la preuve le
président de la république réorganise
ses services
donc sur ce point je pense que le
diagnostic en tout cas est à peu près
partager mais monsieur b maladie et je
crois que c'est exact il était l'adjoint
du chef de cabinet mais comme on
n'arrive pas exactement à déterminer ses
fonctions c'est à dire et est il
seulement un administratif comme parfois
il le prétend ou au contraire
était-il en charge de la sécurité du
président comme honnêtement on le voit
sur un grand nombre d'image
donc il avait un supérieur
chic est-ce que ceux supérieurs
hiérarchiques contrôler ce que faisait
monsieur benalla quelles étaient ses
missions et à quel moment est ce que on
a pu mettre le holà face à des
comportements qui n'étaient pas
admissibles
on a découvert que monsieur benalla
avait un passeport diplomatique avait un
badge qui lui permettait de rentrer dans
l'hémicycle lors qu'il n'était pas
chargé des relations avec le parlement
que bref qu'il allait avoir un
appartement de fonction donc tout ça
nous avons besoin de cerner ses
fonctions parce que si on ne cerne pas
ses fonctions ne sait pas exactement
expliquer à quel moment il a outrepassé
sa compétence de très nombreuses
questions donc que l'on va pouvoir
entendre dès 9h30 sur notre antenne avec
l'audition de françois xavier